welcome to this video its Yardbird again
and minus 1 i'm on minus 1 out of 24
games that's nice okay I'm just doing
something else playing a totally
different type of structure and see what
happens jump this double porn it's not a
big deal definitely ok I want to make
sure that he's not getting away with um
yeah that you can get rid of the the
double porn easily kh5 or something ok I
think that 92 to f4 is this is a good
square for my night aha you think so as
well hey nice ok so I'm going to Castle
him
95 he is playing what exactly night d 5
g fiber move probably not yet d 5 and 94
mmm that looks weird maybe c4 c5 while I
have the chance don't know difficult
stuff if it takes a play Queen d2 this
lodging is might getting into some weird
square ok you can retreat to c6 but one
point of my whole setup is that I'm
trying to make this statement like you
don't have a good good place for your
king which is probably true right here I
guess in case of long castles Queen d3s
a quick activity ok do I take or not
yeah I guess that maybe not maybe not
the thing is he can probably Castle
short
now maybe I should have taken so that
I'm not a porn down you can castle short
yes ma I am and this is this is a slight
problem and want to get any for him and
okay euphoria I need to do that get-get
Nia's King somehow I have those
weaknesses here on the C file Black is
definitely okay here that's that's no
question rupee one
no I guess sure I was thinking rookie to
but it looks a bit passive yeah but
maybe I don't have any any big choice
him
to try to get to the d6 pawn we can
maybe just still take on C to the whole
situation is not not totally clear
because of his somewhat weak porn every
King I still think you should just take
her he doesn't her plane I'd age for his
dropping back to g7 or can I rook see
one looks let's too passive hmm
but I don't see I don't see a great move
let's play it let's play it right here
he can go to age 7
maybe this as usually a very tough
position the ideas if he takes I want to
go look a three attacking the pawn I can
go nite a 5-yard this is this is I can
then i take this except maybe it is not
that bad trying to go for activity here
yeah and that was one idea can you go a
five now then I know and now I am ok I
can do know his Roxy form takes on b6
yeah I can do that take some b6
nie da droopy edge has nice and if you
place Queenie form Wow check
one would be six simply then he gives us
check on you for bh time 187 rooty 696
assess embarrassing
if it can be some wow they don't have
time I really don't have time to to
calculate this to the end now he
probably still can do just King g7 I was
thinking rook f7 but i doubt that this
is working really night at five King g7
is just good but I can move the rook to
e8 maybe and then I have threatened
night at five again yeah I can go look
ahead
night f5 know is a threat yar this I've
feared cakes you can take with the Queen
which is totally crazy but possible
check yeah this is not not bad for me
but I have no time check check check
check check check drop off a check check
check what Worf it's on hi yeah he's
just the same kind of person as many
others are preferring to win some crap
position on time okay what can you do
Wow again a very very very complicated
game with probably chances for both
sides that have been missed yeah
talawanda yeah maybe I could have taken
here but 96 irritated me very very very
very complicated stuff here I probably
embrace yeah yeah I'm the computers oops
that was wrong button compass confirming
that but around here i was getting back
nicely rupee 5 is strong or queen h4
with an attack hmm
yeah this looked really nice so I didn't
think about it that check rook takes age
68 that's funny yeah well right wins
after that but I don't have to I didn't
have time to think about it this is this
is just equal but ok his his time
advantage here was the size of why this
even better yeah yeah it does not matter
with this time control what the position
is like when you have 20 seconds against
13 ok Wow tough game thanks for watching